as we've been hearing we're going to be
heading into a series of days with
really hot temperatures and this is
something we talk about a lot in our
newsrooms like
what do you set your thermostat at when
it's going to be 110 hours right
what's that sweet spot for you and you
got a lot of reactions from this huge
reaction so first of all you weren't
here so what was what do you keep your
thermostat at you and eric i keep it
pretty warm
yeah i i it's at 80. oh that's pretty
that's pretty high and there's a lot of
fans
yeah you gotta keep them consistently
well the reason we bring this up is
because kirsten and brian was here
she keeps hers at 66 degrees i i mean my
mind is like
66 what that bill looks like yeah
right and she said sometimes it's in the
low 60s so here's what people had to say
okay we asked everybody
what do you keep yours at all right
here's our social news desk and you send
it off
on social media julie uh dombrowski says
78 almost all the time that sounds about
right
that's a that's the number that sweet
spot that everybody keeps it at usually
annette magnus says 70 at night 72
during the day
wow that's cool 70. antoine williams 72
at night
during the day and then during the day
if no one's home at 76 degrees
now keep in mind kirsten 66 guys glenn
sanders says 82
she's got you beat thank you gwen
she's got the fans going too big time
big time all right
111 are high for the day today
officially all right that was way above
average we should be 104 this time of
the year 87
is what we dropped to overnight no
record warm low overnight won't
reach that again overnight but we'll
come close to breeding record warm lows
in the next few days here 115 the record
set back in 2007. 100 degrees and above
means our good friends at silver state
refrigeration and hpac will always
donate 100
to vets and pets 112 centenary hills for
you hot up there in centennial hills in
the northwest part of the valley
100's for spring valley and desert
shores 11 north las vegas 113 for you on
the east side 112 for
green valley and also whitney ranch 114
even hotter for you and henderson
and 108 currently for mountains edge and
rhodes ranch 108 for prep 110 for
boulder city and 115
for laughlin right now we're clear here
we had a few storms and showers that
popped up
way east of us into eastern portions of
arizona certainly seeing in colorado
and also new mexico so this heatwave we
call it an extended heatwave because
remember
that heat warning is not in effect just
for three days it's in effect from
wednesday
all the way until monday at 8 pm we're
looking at record busting temperatures
and even tying temperatures on friday
and saturday with 113
and 114 on those specific days certainly
some new
record-breaking overnight lows warm lows
on saturday and sunday 89 overnight
mainly clear and warm 113 for tomorrow
sunny and hotter not going to reach that
116 record but still nonetheless it's
going to be hot
all around the valley look at this one
teens for all of us 111 centennial hills
mountains edge included north las vegas
112. uh nellis or i should say henderson
you'll come in at 111.
115 up in mesquite 108 for prompt
and death valley 125. here is your
extended
eight day extended forecast you'll
notice i put the red colors on here to
indicate how long
that heat warning is is going through
and that's all the way through monday
right
there's your records record-breaking
lows for sure on saturday
and sunday morning and i don't know if
you caught relief but
i'm 109 on tuesday we see those
temperatures start to take a downward
trend we'll take it